Kanye West and Kourtney Kardashian at  step out after Kim's robbery ordeal  here's Kanye exiting his and Kim's New  York City apartment building late  Tuesday kept his eyes covered in a suede  hoodie no expression on his face Kim has  yet to be seen outside since arriving  back to that apartment in New York on  Monday a source telling et the star is  quote absolutely traumatized by the  robbery in Paris back home in Los  Angeles her sister Courtney was spotted  running errands with son Mason she was  decked out on workout gear and smiling  but seemingly stayed silent the whole  Kardashian family has actually stayed at  silent since Kim was robbed save for a  couple unrelated social media posts  Kylie Jenner posted this throwback photo  on Instagram and Rob sent out this tweet